well bill bill burr welcome I've seen
you more like literally in the last two
weeks and I probably have the year
before that you've been like depression
because I went down to the cellar you
know and I I didn't the only familiar
face it was Gary Gulman oh yeah yeah I
saw William Stephenson and I was just
like oh my god somebody I know Gary's
been gone for a while too and then he
kind of came back like six months ago
but he was gone for a little while yeah
so because you don't realize that you
leave but then while you're gone
everybody else leaves too so then when
you go back it's this isn't the place
you left Sam is this is saying out there
you can never go home I guess that's
what and I never knew what that meant
till I got old talking about go home all
the time
right right flight right home what does
that mean though it means you can't go
back to what it was right now it's gone
it's a better time Jim it's a it's it
what we're not leaving a place we're not
leaving a person leaving a moment in
time and that moment in time it it
floats away so what do you have to do
every day Sam cherish the moment cherish
and live in the moment that's well said
what were you gonna say
isolate sexually and pull your blinds
down you can never go home unless you're
going home to masturbate furiously yeah
seventh time this week you get are you
like I find myself you all get like
thinking about [ __ ] and getting
depressed but not even depressor just
said and missing things and like yes ice
white so then I went and I I did my set
or whatever and then there's all these
new comics who literally looked like
children who are our age when I felt I
was old then uh-huh and I was like hey
what's up and all that I was just
getting all [ __ ] you know I was like
I'm just sitting there go on Patrice
used to sit there Jimmy would always sit
there whereas Collin was Bobby and all
that stuff so I kind of said I guys good
night and I just walked away and I was
like I'm ants and I went out because it
was raining out there was no one in the
village and I'm like oh is all the
action in Brooklyn now like yeah just
ran I started walking up 6th Avenue and
had all these memories of me Bobby
Mousavi agree Ryle walking up to like a
diner and [ __ ] and I was like dude I got
to get in a cab all right
gun in my mouth by 18th Street so I
ended up going up the street yeah I kind
of a went back I still have an apartment
here and I finally like went into the
kitchen of it and I had all these old
pots and pans that I got you know let it
gotta be like Target you know the
cheap-ass ones you put the flame up and
you feel like it's gonna come through
the bottom I finally just I had a mix of
that and DeRosa used to rent my
apartment so it was a mix of his old
bachelor [ __ ] which it was just I just
put it all in a bag and just threw it
out I was just like I got to move
forward in Bed Bath & Beyond spent like
400 bucks on brand-new pots and pans so
I could actually [ __ ] cook like a
goddamn human being but you know who's
in the cellar the other night for the
first time in a while he was I think it
was a Friday or Saturday remember
Mustafa
the door guy he was there for the first
time I talked to st Saturday night she
said he was there and I was like ah stop
a little bit of talk to him yeah how do
the young comics treat you do they like
is it are you just hanging out or they
like would neck like are they happy
you're there or is it a chill vibe or
what is it um yeah I think they're fine
and everything are you doing a blah blah
blah blah blah and then you just you
just watch them coming up just being I
know this the young Bobby you see it
there's the guy he's gonna be holding
courts let the young Bobby stop way up
the steps yeah it's just one of those
things so it's that weird thing this
[ __ ] city where it's like when you're
in your 20s it's your city and you don't
realize it because you're living like a
[ __ ] animal right and then like when
you finally get somewhere it's like by
the time you get there everybody's
[ __ ] you know married gone whatever
and yeah you just kind of come down
there like yeah you can't really come
back and enjoy it now that you can't
enjoy it
there's nothing left to enjoy that but
then even if you got it back then
everyone would have resented you for so
you really can't [ __ ] win so really
made me think like I'm really happy I'm
married and I have a kid because then I
just set it up face time in my kid and I
had a great time and right because she
didn't want to talk to me she's like no
no no she waves her hand like Anna I'm
busy my food here Bobby still works
there though I'm still there a lot Keith
Robinson is still there a lot and Colin
Stoll I'm eeen it's just that it depends
if you catch every there at the same
time it's rare but most a lot of the
same guys still go there but it's not
same of course yeah yeah you know people
of people got older yeah all right now
that I've brought it down no I find
myself wrap it up for Ephesus family and
it's good cuz you'll let everybody know
no matter how successful you get even if
all your dreams come true you're still
gonna walk down the street depressed yes
still it all just goes away like raining
like misting and was a perfect Sex in
the City walk was it Miranda whatever
her name is Samantha yeah my wife still
watches that show the fact that I
corrected you quickly we should both be
shot you were trying me for knowing it
yeah she's doing a monologue to your
laptop in chat writing like this city
will eat you up and spit you it's so
campy
it's crazy like I did this thing I kind
of stopped doing it because it was
ruining the show for her but that one
was a Kim Cattrall right yeah beautiful
right but like they gave her character
the same joke every scene for however me
so I always so he's reinforcing her
character so anytime she tells the joke
I think I've already told said this on
your show but I'll be in the other room
whenever she delivers the line I'll be
in the other room and just be like cuz
she's sticking her head in the writers
in like anything can she can she grow
tomatoes in a garden just something give
her some other yeah that was her the
whole thing though right just being a
[ __ ] she's [ __ ] everybody right well
I think you know that's I guess us being
in cave men we should say that you know
how come if a guy does it we should say
that she was she was sexually liberal
good a women know that that's okay like
you if you're the one who [ __ ]
everybody in your group of friends
you're just the Samantha yeah but the
thing is is she talked about it so much
it seemed like she was looking for
attention it seemed desperate right
that's how I broke it down like nobody's
talking about sex right now why are you
bringing this up yeah we're talking
about shoes here and all of a sudden you
know right get it it's your identity you
have something yeah vagina you use it
right it's yours have it I can imagine
of a guy doing that every [ __ ] thing
you do when he's talking about putting
his dick and they probably weren't
really trying to write that like let's
just make her how guys talk you know how
guys are always talking about [ __ ]
everything let's make her
the equivalent of that and it's like
that's not Beach steaks and talk about
[ __ ] things yeah are they women like
that I guess there are I mean women
around each other talk brutally but
[ __ ] dick size yeah but not only that
but are there any women that know how
they just kind of do it on stage yeah
that's true like the biggest dick joke
comics I have to go on now our female
comics yeah
it's [ __ ] hilarious you're sitting
back there it's taking me back to hell
gigs doing Jersey and chicken how the
[ __ ] am I going after this your scribing
your [ __ ] uterine lining Wow yeah
emergency yeah music no I just I just
take him to you know fight off [ __ ] you
know you know just because I can't get
to sleep till 2:00 in the morning with
all the depressing thoughts and
everything sure because I'm not drinking
right now you know so that's usually how
I handle being on the road you know yeah
you know not being able to go home my
family's not there what I do jimmy is I
go out and I get I get just right to the
point of passing out so I could walk it
down in my own apartment not realize
there's no one else there and just
faceplant into the bed then wake up the
next day and go yeah but you you try to
skip those feelings why'd I stop just
because I I'm gonna shoot a special I
know in the next few months and I don't
be that [ __ ] guy who tries to dry out
in ten days all right and then you have
that that's even a worse look you're
better to just keep boozing at that
point see like hey he's living the life
as opposed weird sort of beginning of
rehab yeah you know I don't know I've
just been reading up more on health
stuff I got a kid now so I kind of have
to like I got it every once in awhile I
just sort of tap out for a good you know
one month to six months to a year or
something like that so I was watching
this great thing last night what kind of
drinker are you I was watching this
English guy and you know the way they
drink is you know they have and they you
know the doctors have the same thing the
amount you're supposed to drink in a
week and he's like doing like he has the
app and [ __ ] like that he's like all
right I drink twice this in a night you
know and just the way he was like he had
that same thing that I have works like
I'm not an alcoholic but if you put it
on paper it's just like well then what
are you yeah you see you're not you're
not a you're not a [ __ ] how many out
of 20 did you answer yes to because they
have that whole there's a test you could
take are you an alcoholic 20 questions
so until you're taking that test no but
it's also like I just when I stop
sucks for three days and after four days
it's like I could really just never do
this again right so I don't like wake up
with shakes like I needed and yeah you
know start lashing out at people you're
missing clothes you're missing out on
stuff no but I definitely got to a point
where I wasn't able to just have one
socially like right just like all right
we're doing this would you see the ESPN
you see the 34:30 Ric Flair movie they
did yeah
I did was amazing it was amazing I think
I felt it should have been at least six
hours long but I liked that his was
still like two hours long or something
it was but they started going through
his drinking stories and it was clearly
alcoholism to the point that he was in
the hospital like a year ago and they're
like you you have to stop drinking but
there was no sort of violins or anything
it was just funny that he went to the
doctor and he was like yeah I drink 15
drugs a day he does that him lying
though and just over sedating what he
does cuz now there I mean there's many
witnesses to all this activities yeah oh
yeah he's like 15 drinks a day and the
doctor is like how often he's like whoa
every day for the last 30 years and it's
just it just my favorite favorite thing
just being a comedian because he's the
best guy ever to do the interviews like
it's not even climbing the rock was
amazing but like he's the best ever and
someone said did you have writers did
you did you did you work in above when
he goes he just laughed he goes right as
he goes like because I used to come up
with half of that [ __ ] on the car ride
over from the airport that's just like
you know that's like high-level
performance well you you just come up
I'm gonna talk about that and you just
go out there and he could feel the crowd
yeah and adjust to their energy and all
that he's a lunatic we've a great set of
like that [ __ ] promo like bad rest
incredible to watch I would have loved
though to have been like driving past
Ric Flair and just see him kind of half
mumbling his promos to himself as he was
trying to figure him out just kind of
getting into Ric Flair mode as he's
driving like well the thing about that
guy is when you listen to him like he
loved being it oh my god but and and
then he loved the fans being interested
in him he loves being Ric Flair he loves
doing that and I actually went to the
the premiere that 34:30 oh I had an act
in Atlanta and the guy who directed it
and I got to go to it doing the stores
he was telling and he's just so open
they go you know how uh how faithful
were you free how long were you faithful
to your first wife and he's goes aha he
goes like three days yeah she was there
and he was just going like you know I
was he was just so honest he was home
with his wife and kid he goes I was just
bored I was born like the the social
pressure to be like you know and then I
got a whole new perspective I understood
he could just sit there and be like now
his bored right
I had the Hallmark life and I was bored
and it was just like he was meant to be
out there in front of people and for
some reason I don't know I guess it's
looked I guess when you heard other
people that's a bad thing but I mean it
was it's looked down on that now he's a
[ __ ] rock star he wasn't worried
about missing birthdays and doing all
this other stuff he was like there's so
much fun out here I don't know why you
would want me to be at home at this
kid's birthday party even if it was my
kid what wife that bad for they
definitely the homo monogamy thing was
not his thing at what point is the
ex-wife okay with that like just to go
out there with another people like cats
whatever it's cute I think when the nine
millionth person just goes like dude you
married Ric Flair like what did you
think was gonna plant him blonde hair
down to his shoulders yeah walking
around with hooker boots and tights on
me what did you think this guy was gonna
do yeah they they show a farmers market
they showed him like cutting these
promos and he would go like in front of
the audience and he would announce his
he'd point two girls in the audience and
on television announce his hotel and the
hotel room and his wife would be like
Rick why are you doing that he's like
honey it's all the character and she's
like yeah but that's your actual hotel
room like we didn't have to yeah
actually put the hotel room out there
would they ever show up yeah yeah they
would the invite was real let's not put
him on blast - it's in the dock no it's
all in the 30 so he's old now right was
he [ __ ] 65 70 years old yeah yeah I
think he's in a seven I'm sure he
doesn't care now he doesn't care you
love he love these stories yeah old guys
don't care anymore
no no he's 69 I mean he's these are his
uh his metal
of honor what's is there anything wrong
with him or is he kind of holding up
right he's okay now I mean he was used
bad for a little bit he was in the
hospital and what I can't remember if
his heart gave out but they look they
were they thought he was gonna die for a
while right and but now he's back to
just just like his wrestling match you
thought he was gonna leave back it's all
performance with this guy he kicked out
at two and now he stays backstage at the
shows again like he's just he's back to
being Ric Flair I think it's the
internet is what you know cuz he you
know back when I was growing up but the
others territory so I was in the WWF
territory and he never really wrestled
for Vince until later in his career so I
missed all of that so I you know when I
discovered him on YouTube and just was
one of the great YouTube rabbit holes
ever went down like I think I woke my
wife up I was crying just crying
laughing that first time I saw that my
shoes cost more than your house and the
guy he was talking to you could just
tell it's true he's picking up his shoe
he's got it in his hand and he's shaking
it at him my shoes cost more than your
house I just sit there and like just
brag the privilege that you were born I
was born with a golden spoon in my mouth
just saying I never had to work or
anything and then just saying like vos
ain't no boss cause it's Donna Karen
pulls up the label I mean elements of
Ric Flair you know that's for this
revision his rings Oh
bosses hand rings yeah I I just like
have you seen them I just love how rich
is one of those guys no matter how
classy you dress him he still looks like
a dirtbag he's because he's ugly inside
you gotta get ready yeah yeah those are
bosses I think they're mice and there
might be a little bit of photo shoots no
way you can do that and you have to play
piano if you're gonna be wearing those -
was he [ __ ] Fats Domino there yes and
yeah there's that that's only two es
three he wears yeah five rings on his
fake chunky gold ring because he thinks
it's time to show off he's a man of a
certain means time to show off his
success well I agree I love though he
has those hacky Rose tattoos
why don't you just get a green anchor on
your [ __ ] hair it on your shoulder
they're symbolic I'm sure of many
different things in his life the guy's
almost 73 years old that still takes his
shirt off you know he looks pretty good
he looks great
and he comes in and he's got the jewelry
and that's how you know you don't want a
well-financed you know what I love to he
can't just get the polo shirt that has
the little polo it's got to be like the
giant like it's almost a tattoo whenever
you back in the day whenever used to
wear those shirts are you okay what kind
of shirt is any big and he would
literally go out to pull and they look
down any laughs well yeah because the
problem is if the world goes small
there's a chance that somebody's not
gonna see it but if it's nice and big
everybody knows you paid a lot of money
for this but the rings are a new level
it's a new level of just kind of losing
his mind because for a long time was the
car is the BMW whatever say he had to
have a nice car right show that he was
doing well except he's not good enough
buy the cars off eBay and he gay got the
thing off the shirt off the outlet
stores can't imagine poor Bonnie as he's
sitting this showing off those Liberace
rings go missus class this is class he's
spitting all over the table she hates
the last time Bonnie was in she's just
saying that all this time she thought
that rich was like brilliant and that we
were all the ones not quite getting the
joke and it's only in the last couple
years that she's realized that no that's
not what I will say this as a married
guy the fact that his wife hates him and
he still wears them I love a guy like
that oh yeah cuz that's a guy you can
call up and if you say you want to hang
out you know he'll be able to write
unbendable he's unbendable doesn't
wholly small you know he really is he's
like this is the guy you married and
this is the guy I'm going to Maine I'm
gonna still be this guy forever I love
it's that's probably why he fights so
much because that's the one thing I have
learned yeah yeah that whole ice you
know do a joke about that happy wife
happy life it sounds cute because it
rhymes but it's literally it's a threat
it's like if I'm not happy no one's
gonna be happy including the kids in the
[ __ ] goldfish did you do that from
the from the beginning of being married
like now if I'm
gonna get married I'm not gonna be one
of these guys that falls into married
life uh know what I you know you kind of
learn your defi a few marry you know
someone's smart like I did stupid move
they call you out on all your [ __ ] and
you know you know if you're actually
trying to become a better person they
are making some points like when they're
ripe it is their own crazy [ __ ] cuz
they're crazy you're crazy so and a lot
of it is just your I don't know however
your childhood was it's like why don't
you do things the way my crazy family
did it you know right so but ya know she
makes she makes a lot of good points
well you defuse dangerous che um I go
through great Blake enlightened periods
by meaning for days every once in a
while a four days stretch where I have
really good moments but it's it's more
her but my new thing is I just walk away
when it starts escalating past a certain
point I soundproof my garage so I just
go out and I'll play drums - like
Pantera for like a good half an hour I
don't even give a [ __ ] and I get lost in
whatever Vinnie Paul lick I still can't
do and just slow it down and [ __ ] like
that and then I come out how hard is it
to do that when you first start like the
first couple of times you walk away well
I find if I'm gonna make a change I have
to say it out loud if I think it it's
still buried in all my [ __ ] but I
have to just keep saying I had to walk
around for like weeks going I don't
argue anymore
I don't argue anymore and then I got
rock yes
yeah and I had to say it out loud and
there's a lot of this way more power in
that if as far as trying to be heard
mm-hmm
you know to me because that is one of
the [ __ ] things like just as being
the guy I hate to do like some sitcom
[ __ ] here but it's like literally you
feel I feel like [ __ ] Bruce Willis
and that I see dead people
yeah we sometimes the sense did I die or
something because I just feel like I'm
saying things and nobody's reacting and
yeah or this just always push back like
literally to the point I'm making
oatmeal and she's giving me suggestions
and I was just like a little bee like do
you see what you're doing this is like a
[ __ ] disease now when you say that
when you go do you see this here does
she go like
okay you're right laughs right see last
cuz you know if I'm not mad she laughs
right if you get mad then they're just
like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and but
it's you know she doesn't really name
calls that's the one thing that you know
I know through the name-calling through
that bill changed me on that you made me
realize how [ __ ] up I had been cuz
like I like oh yeah name-calling is bad
so I did I did eventually fall back into
it but I was very conscious of it for a
lot of name-calling terrible you want to
just destroy your case in court name
call yeah I you know I I watched a bunch
of guys growing up doing that all my
friend's dad's my dad they all did the
name-calling thing and yeah I get it
just and then it just builds resentment
yeah you know yeah plus yeah you lose
all ground like you're yeah you're not
even speaking logically that's just an
emotional thing and you know yeah yeah
you have why else would have to
literally be like you've got to do that
thing like you're making me feel like
anytime you say you're making me feel
like somehow it's like you went down the
porthole and all of a sudden they
understand you right but if you're just
going like I mean what the [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] standing here making this if you
do then you'd even name call it if you
tag that with your [ __ ] [ __ ] or
something like that then it then they
just turn around and walk away which
also the brilliant part of them is you
can literally be in a moment where
you're gonna make a good point and if
you get a really really smart woman
she'll she'll [ __ ] get you to that
point will you name call so she still
wins the argument I am convinced to that
I'm just figuring that stuff oh all
right I'm just blaming her for my I'm
just figuring that stuff out now like
I've had arguments with Jess for like
years where it's the same argument over
and over again and why doesn't this work
that's it not you it's me and there was
this moment like where recently I hope
they'll you remember what it was but I'd
go like I hate it when you do this
because it makes me feel like that she
was like oh really yeah yeah that's why
I get it but it feels like an admission
of weakness when you say hey you make me
feel a certain way it's almost like
that's probably it you probably want to
dominate and say you do this and then
win the point we like you make me feel
worthless it's like I feel like it's a
weak point in your hilarious is if your
wife just went you [ __ ] [ __ ] man
I marry does it make you feel bad as it
makes you hard to say that because you
don't want to admit that you're feeling
weak or that she's affecting like just
the first couple of times but then once
you do it and you actually see that oh
this is this is how it's affected I have
to talk you know he actually listened so
yeah that was very I was only like a
week or two ago when I actually said was
it that or in general how did she make
you feel like a natural woman that's
what it was no I don't know it was just
something that like went back to her
like III honestly no III think it was
something where I said something to the
effect of it annoys me when you do this
because I know that that's gonna have
you going like that and then I've got to
deal with that yeah and she goes really
I said yeah and then he went yeah what
the [ __ ] and she's like we I didn't know
that that's why that it was about me and
I'm like what do you think it's about I
gotta tell you another thing you can't
make that face when you make your point
where you squint your eyes and all if it
makes me not like you really yeah I
probably do that all the time no I'm
gonna let another level to your game
okay add a pleasant look on your face
alright maybe yeah if you could just sit
there why did you why'd you think there
you go eyebrows up okay and have your
eyebrows down okay any my my eyes wide
not squint no squint I'm not gonna go
really wide you can't look at them cuz
then if you have your eyes widen along
the way it feels like you're really
thinking about your feelings I saw you
just do it to me just now when you look
down at the tail with the right eyes
like man-birds really really coming from
a deep place right yeah I wasn't yeah I
know absolutely not it was just the
trick if it's the table trick sometimes
you got to set it up first by telling
her what you're not doing like because a
lot of times that you don't somebody be
defensive so you'll go like look I'm not
trying to say that you're a shitty
person and then you kind of go into why
she's a shitty person but if you set it
up by going look I'm not trying to say
this I'm not accusing you it immediately
takes away the weapon they have up don't
accuse me does that work or do they go
5050 okay sometimes sometimes I bet if
that's work you took the word shitty out
of that I'm just saying that to you I
mean I'm not trying to accuse you being
dishonest but I've read your text
messages and they're not what you told
me so calling you a lark but I'm not
saying that you know are you going I
know that sometimes communication gets
weird
I don't think this whole by we're gonna
[ __ ] him but apparently you are so maybe
miscommunicate absolutely I'm not trying
to call you a disloyal Pig I'm just
saying this might be what happened right
right but set it up remove that exit
because like you said as soon as you
named cual or whatever they [ __ ] they
win the argument so if you've got that
exit you got to give somebody an out
yeah they can they they you got to give
that you can't just paint them into a
corner because they're gonna come out
swinging you got to give them a
respectable that was a great thing that
I saw you know George Herbert Walker
Bush dying where they said the way he
handled the Berlin Wall coming down he
didn't rub it in the Russians faces like
yeah see we were right and you know we
won he just he let them you know he let
them go away gracefully it was you know
right which is kind of all that is
disappeared social medias was the worst
[ __ ] thing it's just it's awesome
it's awesome if you're a performer
uh-huh you know to promote your shows
but as far as just giving somebody an
out like you don't you don't see that
much know what's gonna fight you guys
want to find a bar or there's an issue
with two men no guy most times wants to
fight and most guys just don't want to
deal with that but you have to give each
other a way to kind of back away without
being seen as a total coward in front of
everybody dude I was at a LA Kings game
and I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
he's two guys got into it one guy was
like he was big and the other guy was
was a smaller guy and he walked up I
figured what the guy did well he stood
up and he got any and some of his beer
went on the bigger guy and the guy
walked up to him and he just teaches
[ __ ] slapped his glasses like
sunglasses office off his face and then
the guy it was like what the [ __ ] and
then he wound up like he was gonna throw
the sickest punch ever and he stopped
right in front of the guy's nose and the
guy flinched and he just laughed at him
and he went back to his seat and the guy
was just standing there like what the
[ __ ] and then the second somebody put
the hand in front of him all of a sudden
he was the toughest guy ever and then
for the rest of the fight everyone was
trying to hold him back he had so much
time so I was being a dick I was like
let him go
to calm him to calm down just don't put
anything in front of him cuz this that
but what the thing was is his wife I
think gave him the out because he was
just gonna stand there and do nothing
she went like that and gave you know
like what a good woman yeah that was
really cool that she did that because
there was nothing to hold back there
because he wasn't wait who Flint think
big I flinched no no the big guy just
totally just I guess the young kid says
punked him he just made him he just
exposed him for the punk that he was the
big guy slapped a little guys glasses
off yeah and then the little guy cocked
back no I had words and then he just
went shut the [ __ ] up but he went like
that and the guy flinched anyone like
and then it was like a white dude the
bigger guy and he looked like his dad
had money and just you know I'm just
doing all the type so everybody in that
section hated him because that's the way
it is now I mean you know he's a white
guy with a great head of hair so
obviously he has problem he's got to be
the [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's a good one woman who's
like you know I don't want you to sheep
you know he put the 11 for the guy who
had his glasses slapped off yeah
sunglasses just seems not like this
nerdy guy so and then he was trying to
do all that what's up [ __ ] and try to
do all of it I actually saw a lot of
love in their relationship great that is
flat for her too though that's for her
too so she doesn't feel like it doesn't
dry up yeah realizes she married a guy
that what is glass what he's [ __ ] her
she just sees like a little red mark on
the bridge of his nose do you want to
take the beating I mean you gotta throw
the punch you just get beat up but now
you're talking session you don't you
know why cuz nobody knows who the [ __ ]
you are and just just leave because the
only things gonna happen in that
situation is either you're gonna lose or
you're gonna win and then you get sued
or you gotta get arrested so pick
[ __ ] pinion you don't tell me if your
wife is there like you have to go back
out what are you talking about in the
car on the way home like you both know
close game thing what you did was the
right thing to do but they don't respect
you right as a certain part of them
don't respect you yeah they want you to
swing I think so and they always say the
oh I don't I don't want you to there's
some women that wouldn't want you to
fight
to be with an enlightened human being
but in that moment I would think that
they'd want you I would think that she
would [ __ ] him better had he thrown the
punch anybody lost I had to defend your
owner they feel like they're in some
movie yeah Oh rocky for thee that's
where the emotions take or emotionally
she would love a guy that would defend
her but logically she knows that she
just wants a like you said an
enlightened man yeah you know what some
guy that's getting in a barroom fight
Simon's [ __ ] ridiculous was a little
guy who got his glasses knocked off
that's it's embarrassing
you think it's embarrassing sure
especially didn't mean that spill is
beer hey listen I think we've all been
that little guy getting his glasses now
we've only been that little yeah I've
never been the other guy no no me
neither
you know you didn't bully anybody as you
were coming up do you think I had the
opportunity to believe people yeah I
made some point you were bolder than the
kids below you yeah but I was only wait
yeah I was still smaller them like I was
a growth hormone as a kid I was a shrimp
yeah oh you were yeah yeah yeah I
started taking growth hormone when I was
humiliating like 13 years old oh now I
get why you squint when you're trying to
make a point it was all those years of
looking up into the sunny it's not a
condescending thing it's just a thing I
was a little fella yeah that's all the
way for yes I mean I didn't hit average
height until you know the end of high
school and by then you know no so worse
is when you open up about that kind of
paint to your wife or girlfriend and
they go like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
didn't have to add that yeah it doesn't
make me feel better at all makes you
feel much you're like a good dose of
sympathy I don't mind a little dosa from
Oh from woman if it's justified I don't
like people making sounds like they're
looking at a puppy struggling to drink
out of its dish right that level of
sympathy is like oh I can't even
function as a human yeah you don't need
it oh I like a little do you know if
it's warranted yeah something like that
I defend a lot of my lunatic behavior
though you get into I go well that's why
it's decos part of the whole [ __ ]
deal
right-ho deal the reason why I'm able to
come up with material
is because I am a volatile [ __ ] idiot
and I make a lot of mistakes right hence
we get to live a great lifestyle you
know you want it you want an even keeled
guy is that what you want she's like
that doesn't really apply to any one
little [ __ ] one-bedroom apartment
I've tried that it never worked at all
with girlfriends you know don't call me
a [ __ ] you like flying first-class what
you can't do the name-calling thing oh
that's right it kind of is so when
you're when your wife points out
something that you're like dude you have
no real estate left if you call a woman
a cutout that's that's like roll credits
end of movie yes you probably hit it
within the first five to ten minutes
where we're going from here it's it's
usually the lead necklace you're in
diamonds just right non [ __ ] right now
no I'm not dating now but just to take
it back next time I date so I'm not
gonna do that I'm you're not gonna call
them a con I know I mean I don't want to
get into Iligan you know I tell you Bill
really made me think about this [ __ ]
I don't want to be in that situation so
when your wife funny cuz you taught me
about hecklers what about him I saw and
I never I thought I told you this one
night I saw him at Caroline's and my
thing was I was so defensive when I was
on stage forget about off stage that any
of anybody was talking in the crowd they
of course were saying this guy sucks
when is the next guy coming on and I
would just chop people's [ __ ] heads
off right and afterwards they come up we
were just ordering and it wasn't until I
saw Jim one time just said he goes
what'd you say and they said even what
they said back he was oh okay okay okay
and he just kind of kept going I'm just
that was that the I didn't know you
could do that yeah but that goes back to
the argument with your wife I wasn't
yelling at hecklers I wouldn't have been
this YouTube guy and have that come up
every single time that is my last resort
that's my last but then I always make
her laugh at that okay you want that
even keel cuz you want that guy on top
of you that's how you start you like
intimacy with you when we I enjoy
missionary style looking in your eyes
connecting on a human level when you
when she points out of behavior that
when you're like yeah she's right do you
know as soon as she says yeah she's
right and like that cools it out or do
you have to get through a fight and then
afterwards
like okay I'll work on them it depends
on how much I'm on my game if I'm on my
game if she says something she's right
you're right you're right yeah I'm bad
about that I don't know it gives you so
much but it gives you so much
credibility if you go Adam every [ __ ]
time then you're just a [ __ ] lunatic
[ __ ] right a fuse if you actually say
you know you're right you're right I'm
gonna work on that that gives you
credibility for the next time you argue
with them because if you're arguing with
them and then you don't name call and
you say that's making me feel this way
it [ __ ] sucks because they don't seem
to have to adjust their [ __ ] you know
it's always adjusting to their to them
yeah yeah yeah hi what I see feels good
sometimes though like when I [ __ ] up
and I'm still like look I was I was
really being I had no right to say that
to you and I'm really sorry and they are
very always taken by it but sometimes it
feels really nice to do that no no it is
it is it's definitely it's definitely
writing I feel like we're doing the male
view right well yeah I think it's it's
important we hunt around I mean I still
guys squinting your eyes again you
really are try it again gradually look
okay looking down at the ground you know
I just think it's important that we talk
about our feelings you see the
difference Oshin disgusting I can't look
at that every morning I don't mind me
open to me like this [ __ ] no I don't
like that horrible woman come on
Jim I know you can get a trust me I know
I don't like I don't like to look down I
want to compromise the middle like I
don't like the squint is horrible and
the open eyes is okay okay look down
makes me want to [ __ ] smash your face
okay so just try and open okay like
don't you think that sometimes we should
talk about our feelings I agree
you did somewhere with your voice yeah
as soon as I said that I was like that
sounds like a line you're not ordering a
[ __ ] truck just okay yeah but don't
you think that sometimes we should talk
about our feelings I do is that good
that much but you're in your head right
now yeah too much attention there's a
look down again I'll give you one more
shot to looked up maybe I was wrong okay
okay but sometimes I feel like we should
we should just talk about our feelings
it's disgusting okay you don't you hate
it I love you it's fake sheepish that's
I go it just doesn't feel genuine at all
for him looking down like gosh shucks
ma'am but yet none of this is genuine no
I
that looks fake this tecnique him
looking at me literally really is a
reality show right now yeah I should
teach guys how to try and win are doing
it wrong firstly with the hidden camera
in the house it's like a part of their
head it's all parlor trick yeah it's bar
rescue but for arguments where you're
really just putting new barstools out
it's the same same dysfunctional people
in the heart getting into the [ __ ]
the little minutiae of people's
relationships that's fascinates me this
what when people do to each other that's
right and wrong i'ma tell you at just
whatever I told you and I'm telling
walking away just like I'm not one of
mine arguing with you anymore
alright just do what you want to do I'm
walking away then they want to [ __ ]
they actually want to know what is going
on with you it's [ __ ]
I've try to actually just sit there and
argue with them you just you just it's
you'll discover why you're gonna die
before she is are you are you I hang up
on her in an argument guy will you hang
up the phone in argument I saved those
because those those really make a
statement so you have to look big I'm
big on hitting the mute button and then
saying what I want to say and then I
yeah what's worse than hanging up on
somebody and they don't call you back in
a minute you're like I'm not done and
then you start facetiming back and
they're not picking up and you're like
oh you pieces I know I'm so weak yeah
[ __ ] yeah I tend to when I know jess is
right I'll argue to like to the bitter
end like we keep the fight going
and then I'll improve on the behavior
even though I argued about it and then
that way I can say why I improved on and
I listen to you I was right but I'll
never in yeah that's the argument the
words I'll never be able to actually
just stop and go you know what I am
gonna work on that it takes like an hour
after we're done fighting but the worst
thing happens I do that all the time yes
have you noticed have you noticed how
much better I've been you know yeah
didn't agree I [ __ ] annoying
I hate yep except if you don't do it
because she's gonna point out all the
times you
don't change so you've got to point out
the times no it really is the whole
thing is just a mindfuck it is they're
trying to just it's and it's something
that is not discussed at all it at all
like this this this is this whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] out there that women
don't have power it's it's ridiculous
yeah like you know I did that gig down
the street you know it [ __ ] msg I got
oh yeah there yes 36 hours later uh-huh
after doing that gig standing ovations
Madison Square Garden in the round 36
hours later I'm walking on eggshells in
my own don't even [ __ ] tell me that
you don't have they run the [ __ ] show
their genius is that they always depict
themselves as victims that's that's the
if that's the genius of them yeah and if
you call him out on that you sound like
this crazy person saying the world is
flat because this you know you know this
whole [ __ ] pressure out there now to
just sit there and just you know you
know specifically with white women to
sit there and act like like their lives
are just like a greased uphill climb
it's it's [ __ ] real like you a white
woman with blond hair the United States
of America like what is the [ __ ]
problem people pay attention and I say
you don't have problems but look at some
other people's problems and compare them
to yours and like what exactly is the
[ __ ] problem yet this weekend it was
like I literally was sitting there
saying I brought up something I was like
yep my dad keeps asking me about this
and it's driving me crazy just didn't
asked me about the thing I just said you
know in the middle of a conversation I
was like yeah my dad is driving me crazy
he keeps asking me about this and she
goes well what's happening with it and
as a Jess are you asking me about the
thing I just told you is driving me
crazy
well you know if your father was right I
bet I was like I was like I don't want
to I don't want to talk about it right
now I just told you trip me crazy she's
like what you never want to talk about
what why I'm like what I don't even it
was it was my new show is not God but
but I was like I was like I was like I
just dude I just felt something in my
chest when she did second that you just
said it well you never want to talk
about things yeah I was like sure you
just roll the window down as you
like it's like it's like I okay that
hello over home please right cuz it's a
gurbin told that in traffic or in the
car that you don't want to talk about
things come on dude I mean I've been
with my wife for 15 years and yeah I've
had all of those I've had her say pull
over let me out uh-huh dude oh
Thanksgiving we I never heard that but
I've heard why are you pulling over I
know I we had some food some funk and we
laughed about it through it this [ __ ]
hilarious fight on Thanksgiving when we
were prepping the food and all of that
and I was over by the basket or
something like that like you know peanut
potatoes or something and I said
something because I was so [ __ ] mad I
didn't give a [ __ ] and I just was
[ __ ] letting her have it and she just
put down the [ __ ] knife or something
like that she just came walking over and
got right in my grille I can't remember
what the [ __ ] she said but she was
talking like and next time and I was
like she gonna hit me and afterwards we
[ __ ] for like an hour were laughing
[ __ ] mad and she was laughing how
ridiculous was that she got in my face
she got in my face like a [ __ ]
wrestling promo like she was gonna body
slam me and she was so mad I kind of
felt like it was going to happen but but
she has an incredible sense of humor so
you know we're able to laugh off a lot
of that [ __ ]